nothing seedy went on guys it wasn't
weird
weirder things have happened in that
castle
Sam Smith telling it like it is it's
time for my uh villain era I think Sam's
receiving backlash over their music
video for I'm not here to make friends
[Music]
it's sparking debate over revealing
outfits and dance routines and now Sam's
addressing it all basically it's set in
the castle it's like King Henry that's
Castle
nothing seedy went on guys it wasn't
weird
Sam even clarifies on The Graham Norton
Show that the set was open to the public
yeah they were working around us okay I
had no idea what was going on in the
rooms where the things have happened in
that castle
yeah and their tweet over the weekend
kind of sums it up sharing this pic from
the video writing never too much that's
music that's the beauty of music I'm not
in control of that
um I make music write songs throw them
out in the air and hope that it touches
people so I'm very happy when it does
while many are calling out Sam's choices
others are defending the star if Nicki
Minaj can wear a thong in Anaconda if
Miley Cyrus get my nipple tassels at
Music Awards if Harry Styles got my
dress in Vogue magazine Sam can do
whatever they want professional dancer
Sam Salter slams trolls for the double
standard if you have a problem with it
you are the problem even subconsciously
if you don't want to have a problem with
it but it makes you feel uncomfortable
that's fine but you need to you've got
some learning to do and you do not
qualify to drag people down on the
internet
to make friends
[Music]
and Sam keeps it real when it comes to
inspiration behind the new single I went
on a date with this guy and he just
people friend zoned me a lot on dates
like and I went in studio the next day
and I was like I'm sick of like I've got
enough friends I don't need any more
friends
and so the songs about that Yep they're
ready for fans to see this new era of
music yeah time to get sexy it's just it
gets better you know I really hope that
people enjoy it the way that I am I love
it
foreign